Draconian bills to restrict self-defense rights have a life of their own in Congress.
There's always one lurking in the background. Left to its own devices, it's unlikely to become law,
but it's ready to be deployed if a suitable high-profile crime or a convenient crisis emerges
to ease its passage. And that brings us to the Gun Violence Prevention and Community Safety Act of 2020.
A far-reaching bill hovering in the legislative shadows as the COVID-19 pandemic breaks down barriers
to authoritarian measures. Introduced in the Senate and the House at the end of January, by Senator
Elizabeth Warren of Massachusetts and Representative Hank Johnson of Georgia, the bill would impose
federal licensing for guns and ammunition, require universal background checks,
ban so-called assault weapons, outlaw normal capacity magazines, regulate DIY firearms,
and otherwise impose the full wish list of restrictions sought by those who would prefer to see
an armed government ruling over disarmed citizens. With its massive intrusions into rights cherished by
much of the population, the proposed law is a recipe for massive non-compliance,
confrontations between people and enforcers, and deepened political divisions. It's also exactly the
sort of legislation that is normally dead on arrival, but these aren't normal times.
Officials with fever dreams of expanded power thrive on our fear. "As the Coronavirus pandemic brings the world
to a juddering halt, and anxious citizens
demand action, leaders across the globe
are invoking executive powers and
seizing virtually dictatorial authority
with scant resistance,"  The New York Times warned on March 30th.
The restrictions described in the
article are wide-ranging covering
everything from detaining people to
surveillance the censorship of speech
aimed at politicians and their policies
the Department of Justice has floated
the idea of indefinite detention
California governor Gavin Newsom
speculated about the possibility of
martial law if we feel the necessity
Washington DC's mayor Muriel Bowser
wants to arrest anybody who ventures
from home for an unapproved reason and
jurisdictions across the country have
ordered or considered ordering gun
stores along with other non-essential
businesses closed for the duration of
the crisis in selling their gun bill
Warren and Johnson play on the fears of
many members of the public
and their desire to be saved from unseen
perils in a joint January 30th press
release trumpeting their gun bill Warren
and Johnson described a country rife
with violence in homes and on sidewalks
in schools and supermarkets in places of
worship and workplaces it invoked fear
of a false crisis involving a made-up
epidemic just as a real crisis sized
epidemic was rolling into our lives that
potent combination of real and overblown
crises doesn't mean that the gun
violence prevention and Community Safety
Act of 2020 will pass but it does mean
that this is a ripe moment for
authoritarian laws and practices of all
sorts it also means that this particular
legislative monstrosity is being sold in
precisely the most effective way for
such a moment and pushback is an
important just for self-defense rights
it's a necessary part of a larger effort
to put government's on notice they must
stop exploiting our fear to expand their
power